>>> THIS JUST IN TO CNN, THE
CITY OF CHESAPEAKE, VIRGINIA HAS
RELEASED NEW INFORTION ABOUT
THE WALMART EMPLOYEE WHO OPENED
FIRE ON HIS CO-WORKERS KILLING
SIX PEOPLE BEFORE TAKING HIS OWN
LIFE.
TWO PEOPLE REMAIN HOSPITALIZED
INCLUDING ONE OF THEM IN
CRITICAL CONDITION.
CITY OFFICIALS SAY THE SHOOTER
PURCHASED THE HANDGUN THE VERY
MORNING OF TUESDAY'S ATTACK.
CNN'S DIANNE GALLAGHER HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS STORY FOR US.
AND THEY ALSO RELEASED A MESSAGE
THAT THE GUNMAN HAD LEFT ON HIS
PHONE.
WHAT DO WE KNOW?
>> Reporter: YEAH, JIM, THIS IS
THE BIGGEST DEVELOPMENT IN THE
POLICE INVESTIGATION THAT WE'VE
HAD SINCE THAT SHOOTING THAT
CLAIMED THE LIVES OF SIX PEOPLE
AT WALMART IN CHESAPEAKE,
VIRGINIA ON TUESDAY.
ACCORDING TO THE CITY OF
CHESAPEAKE, POLICE DID A
FORENSIC ANALYST OF THE
SHOO
SHOOTER'S PHONE THEY FOUND ON
THE SCENE AND DETERMINED THERE
WAS A NOTE ON THE PHONE ENTITLED
DEATH NOTE ON THE PHONE.
THEY RELEASED A GREEN GRAB OF
THAT ON THEIR TWITTER ACCOUNT
THIS MORNING.
LOOK, THE NOTE TALKS ABOUT HIS
GRIEVANCES AGAINST HIMSELF,
AGAINST HIS CO-WORKERS.
IT TALKS AT LENGTH ABOUT GOD AND
THE HOLY SPIRIT AND FEELING
INADEQUATE AND ANGRY ABOUT
THINGS.
LOOK, WE DON'T TALK A LOT ABOUT
THESE BECAUSE THEY'RE EXCUSES
FOR MURDERING PEOPLE, SIX PEOPLE
AT THAT WALMART.
BUP I DO WANT TO READ READ YOU
TWO EXCERPTS FROM THIS HERE
SAYING THE ASSOCIATES GAVE ME
EVIL TWISTED GRINS AND MOCKED ME
AND CELEBRATED MY DOWNFALL LAST
DAY.
THAT IS WHY THEY SUFFER THE SAME
FATE AS ME.
IT ALSO SAID I WISH I COULD HAVE
SAVED EVERYONE FROM MYSELF, MAY
GOD FORGIVE ME FOR WHAT I'M
GOING TO DO.
AGAIN IT WAS ENTITLED DEATH
NOTE.
THE CITY ALSO ADDING THAT THERE
WERE TALKS ABOUT SEARCH WARRANT
THAT WAS EXECUTED AT THE
SHOOTER'S HOME, ANDRE BEING 31
AFTER THE SHOOTING OCCURRED,
THEY SAY THAT A BOX OF MO
AMMUNITION, IN REFERENCE TO THE
9 MILLIMETER SEMI-AUTOMATIC
HANDGUN IN ADDITION TO THE HOME
AND IN A BOX RECEIPT AND OTHER
PAPERWORK.
AND AGAIN HE PURCHASED THAT GUN
ON THE MORNING OF THE SHOOTING
THERE ON TUESDAY.
AND LOOK, MOST IMPORTANT IN ALL
OF THIS, THE COMMUNITY OF
CHESAPEAKE TRYING TO RECOVER
FROM THIS REELING FROM THAT
SHOOTING AND THOSE VICTIMS WHO I
WANT TO SHOW THEIR FACES AND SAY
THEIR NAMES AGAIN BECAUSE THEY
ARE CENTER OF THIS SHOOTING.
LORENZA GAMBLE, BRIAN PENDLETON,
KAYLEE PILE AND DANICA JOHNSON
AND A 16-YEAR-OLD BOY KILLED ALL
WORKING AT WALMART.
THEY WERE CO-WORKERS OF THAT
SHOOTER ANDRE BING WHO AGAIN WAS
THE OVERNIGHT TEAM LEAD AT
WALMART ACCORDING TO THE COMPANY
AND HAD BEEN WITH WALMART SINCE
2010.
MANY OF THE SURVIVORS WE SPOKE
WITH DESCRIBED THE SHOOTER AS
SOMEBODY WHO WAS OFTEN PARANOID
OR WAS CONDESCENDING OR TO THEM
OR MEAN TO THEM AS EMPLOYEES BUT
THEY DIDN'T EXPECT THIS WOULD BE
THE WAY THIS TURNED OUT.
>> THE WEAPON BOUGHT THE VERY
SAME DAY.
DIANNE GALLAGHER, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> YEP.
>>> WELL, IN THE WAKE OF ALL OF
THE SHOOTINGS, THIS TIME IN
VIRGINIA AND COLORADO, PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID HE STILL WANTS TO GET
AN ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN PASSED IN
CONGRESS.
BUT WITH JUST OVER A MONTH UNTIL
REPUBLICANS TAKE CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE, DEMOCRATS HAVE A SHORT
WINDOW TO MOVE ON REALLY ANY OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES.
HERE WAS THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY.
>> THE IDEA THAT WE STILL ALLOW
SEMI AUTOMATIC WEAPONS TO BE
PURCHASED IS SICK.
JUST SICK.
IT HAS NO, NO SOCIAL REDEEMING
VALUE.
ZERO.
NONE.
NOT A SINGLE SOLITARY RATIONAL
FOR IT INSTEAD OF PROFIT FROM
THE GUN MANUFACTURERS.
>> CAN YOU DO ANYTHING DURING
THE LAME DUCK.
>> I WILL TRY.
>> DURING THE LAME DUCK.
>> I HAVE TO MAKE THAT
ASSESSMENT AS I GET IN AND START
COUNTING THE VOTES.
>> JOINING ME NOW, TOLLA, FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
>> DON'T WANT TO ELIMINATE ANY
POSSIBILITY, BECAUSE LAST FEW
YEARS IN WASHINGTON HAVE TOLD US
TO ALWAYS ALLOW THE POSSIBILITY
TO BE SURPRISED.
BUT I MEAN, IS THERE A POTENTIAL
MOVEMENT ON AN ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN WHICH WOULD, YOU KNOW,
RESURRECT SOMETHING THAT THIS
COUNTRY DID DO A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
>> YEAH, JIM, THE MATH JUST IS
NOT THERE FOR THAT KIND OF LAW.
EVEN AT THIS MOMENT WHEN
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO PUSH FOR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF GUN LAWS IN
THE HOUSE.
IT IS RUN INTO A BLOCKADE IN THE
SENATE WHERE YOU HAVE THE
FILIBUSTER RULE.
SO THERE IS A VERY LOW
LIKELIHOOD THAT THIS WILL PASS
DURING THE LAME DUCK, EVEN
THOUGH THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO
GETTING?
DONE.
HE TALKED ABOUT WHAT HE WAS ABLE
TO GET DONE WITH A MODEST BILL
ON GUN SAFETY.
BUT IN TERMS OF THIS MORE
FAR-REACHING EFFORT, IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THE MATH IS THERE AND
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE GOING TO
TAKE CONTROL IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS SAID THEY HAVE NO INTEREST
IN RESTRICTING GUN RIGHTS AT ALL